[Music]
a debate over how the government manages
its budget
is taking over capitol hill the key word
is reconciliation reconciliation
i'm willing to go to reconciliation
budget reconciliation is a process that
speeds up law making
that may come in handy for washington's
majority party this summer
while a bipartisan group reached an
agreement to spend more than one
trillion dollars on infrastructure in
june
this is roads and bridges but also lots
of other kinds of infrastructure
democrats also want to pass the american
family's plan to shore up the country's
social safety net
republicans and this group did not want
to go along with
my family plan issues the child care tax
credits
the human infrastructure that i talk
about in total the president wants to
spend six trillion dollars in fiscal
year 2022.
in order to get anywhere close to that
level of spending democrats will need to
use budget reconciliation
but there's no guarantee that this will
work divisions within the party could
scuttle the entire process
here's how budget reconciliation works
and why democrats are using it to pass
biden's agenda
every fiscal year congress has an
opportunity to pass a new budget bill
this is an opening to pass laws with a
simple majority without needing 60 votes
to overcome a filibuster
let's be clear the purpose of this in
many ways from a partisan perspective
is to get around the 60-vote hurdle
on regular legislation bill hoagland has
worked on congressional budgets
for more than three decades there had
been something like about 22
reconciliation bills enacted into law
and i
was involved in about 18 of those
here's how the reconciliation process
works
when a party controls the house senate
and white house
it can write the government's budget the
first draft of the budget is called a
budget resolution
this document can include reconciliation
instructions
for one or more committees to change
existing rules on spending
revenue or debt these instructions allow
the controlling party to fold its goals
into the budget
instead of passing them as regular laws
that are subject to filibusters
once a budget resolution passes the next
step is committee review
where members of congress write policies
that deliver what the reconciliation
instructions
ask for for example the transportation
committee
may receive instructions that affect
road building programs
these instructions can ask the committee
to change how much is spent
how much tax is collected or how much
debt the country takes on
for this program but new policies
sometimes
depend on rules and regulations that
don't directly affect the budget
and might not pass in reconciliation
it's not out of the realm of possibility
that you couldn't create new spending or
new taxes or new provisions
but yet but it has to have a direct
fiscal impact
once the recommendations are finalized
they're sent to the senate budget
committee
this group verifies that the revised
plan changes the budget in a way that
follows the rules of congress
after passing committee review the
budget is sent to the senate chamber for
final consideration on the floor
a budget reconciliation bill carries
special privileges which can speed up
its passage
for starters there is a 20 hour time
limit to review the proposed changes
in the normal law making process debate
is what makes capitol hill stall
out often in the form of a filibuster a
reconciliation bill avoids the
filibuster and can pass with a simple
majority
in the event of a tie which is possible
in today's split senate
the vice president steps in to cast a
tie-breaking vote
if the vote passes both chambers of
congress the reconciliation bill then
heads to the president's desk
where it can be signed into law
making rules in this manner comes with
caveats for instance
reconciliation measures are supposed to
focus on the budget impacts
and little else this is one of several
restrictions
put in place by the senate's bird rule
the biggest one
is a provision says does the provision
in reconciliation is it merely
incidental to an overall policy if it
doesn't pass that test then any united
states senator
can stand up and say mr president that
provision
xyz violates the byrd rule i raise a
budget act point of order
and it is and unless there's 60 votes to
waive that point of order that
particular provision is surgically
removed doesn't kill the bill
just simply takes it out early in 2021
the senate parliamentarian's
interpretation of the byrd rule
forced democrats to abandon a piece of
the covet 19 bill
this reconciliation bill does not
include an increase
in the minimum wage to 15 an hour in my
view it should have
democrats are on a tight timeline to
pass laws that affect many areas
including infrastructure climate change
taxes
paid sick leave unemployment payments
child care
and education programs it's a lot to get
done before the 2022 campaign cycle
kicks off when we get into next year
uh fiscal year 20 budget resolution 23
then it becomes so
much more partisan that made more even
more difficult to achieve
agreements in order to use budget
reconciliation in an
evenly split senate democrats need
everyone in the party to fall in line
that puts all eyes on moderate democrats
like joe manchin who could vote no on a
reconciliation bill
and prevent any laws from passing if
they think in reconciliation
i'm going to throw caution to the wind
and go to five or six trillion dollars
when we can only afford one or one and a
half or maybe two
and what we can pay for then i can't be
there
with the spending figures piling up and
time running out
this year's budget talks are shaping up
to be a particularly high-stakes
negotiation